[Music]
[Applause]
hello everyone thank you usually i try
to talk about the cool stuff like
typescript or graphql but today it will
be something slightly different it will
be about how your bundle size can save
the climate because i think often as
developers we try to think about making
our code look pretty
we hopefully try to think about
accessibility making our code accessible
to everyone that tries to use it but we
hardly think about the effects of the
climate of the code we write so your
bundle size can actually make a
difference and a stitch is
a bit gave away maybe even javascript
isn't the best solution possible but
we'll see we'll see
before i will give you some stats to get
you thinking about why your bundle size
and the climate can be important for you
as a javascript developer
so in 2021 the average website was four
times bigger than 10 years before and
this actually is that coming from the
internet archive for the http archive
and they collect information about the
web and all the websites in general so
four times bigger than 10 years ago
and also the internet in total so this
is data centers this is network this is
mobile phones computers everything
related to it is using over 20 of all
global energy so even when we're today
maybe it's even more because we have a
lot of tech people in one room
the internet is using a lot of our
energy so we need to be sure that we use
this energy efficiency
and also something else i keep hearing
about it is also if you're a harry
potter fan i am
it's this great scene about lingardi in
leviosa you're actually pronouncing it
wrong you often see the same with
climate change so it might not be a hot
day today or maybe it's actually climate
change so try and think about this when
you're watching this talk
it's a little bit about myself so my
name is roy i'm from amsterdam i work
for a graphql company called steps in
i write programming books and i speak at
conferences so i'm really glad to see
everyone here today
[Applause]
so what has changed we already saw the
average website was four times bigger
than 10 years ago so what has actually
changed that we're now using so much
energy and we have so large websites
so one of its phone zombies i don't know
if you saw any phone zombies today i saw
some of them luckily not that much
because people are actually interacting
with each other which is great to see
but phone zombies are actually a thing
but it's also a bit exaggerated of
course because not everyone is using the
phone all the time but we are using our
phone more and more
we spend more time online than we did
before and i think every year it's
getting bigger and bigger this number
and mobile phones have actually become a
first screen so no longer do you need to
go to a desktop computer that maybe is
at your attic or at your bedroom today
your mobile phone is in your pocket all
day and it's consuming internet and it's
browsing to websites
so what else is change
we're also shopping online i remember
some quotes from people 20 years ago
saying maybe the internet will get
somewhere i think today everyone is
shopping online and you actually see
that over three quarters of all people
buy something online every month
even our groceries have gone online now
and you can even get a set of bananas at
your house within 15 minutes in most
countries
so is this actually the problem is it
does javascript developers or is it
maybe all those boxes delivered at your
home so i've been away for a week
hopefully this won't be by my front door
but there's something else that has
changed also which is the web itself
as we already saw in 2021 the websites
were four times bigger than they were 10
years ago so something has changed there
as well maybe it's all the content we
produce or maybe it's the websites we
create or maybe it's something that
builds our websites
i actually saw some things on twitter
and i also asked people what is your
javascript bundle size does anyone you
know what the javascript bundle size is
i don't see many hands so people
probably won't know
so i asked on twitter and some people
said it's below two megabytes which i
think is hard to do unless you maybe
have a portfolio website some people
thought it was between two megabytes and
five megabytes but the weirdest part is
nobody knows sometimes you know how fast
your website loads you maybe know how
your energy bill at home is or what you
pay for your mobile cell phone but you
have no idea for the code that you ship
how expensive it is for all the people
reading and using your website so bundle
sizes are important
but before let's take one step back
before we actually have a bundle size so
what will happen you're with your team
you're at home
or maybe you're a solo developer and
you're building a website the actual
programming language that you use for
this website is maybe as important as
the actual code that you ship
if you look at stack overflow
we actually see that javascript html css
are the biggest programming languages
out there and i don't want to get in the
discussion if html and css is actually a
programming language so maybe try and do
that with a beer after this talk and
also python python has also been
increasing a lot more and more people
are using python
and it's for a reason right because just
as javascript it's an accessible
language that's easy to learn relatively
of course
but most of all javascript has been in
the top it was popular 10 years ago but
now it has even become more popular
i'm not even sure why sql is listed here
but who cares
and then some people sometimes ask me
questions so yesterday i was walking
around some people ask me what will you
be speaking about so i was talking about
your bundle size and the climate and how
you as a programmer can actually make
improvements here and then someone asked
me is the fest language always energy
efficient
does someone think so fast language is
energy efficient by default
i don't see many ants or maybe people
don't dare to raise their hands so we're
going to look at a fast language is it
actually energy efficient
if you had physics you maybe know that
energy is times
against the power and this is irregular
physics
so you would have energy and energy is
composed of the time and the power that
you put into it so this is how physics
works if you had some physics at your
high school you maybe know
but not on our world because we're of
course we're software developers
programmers our rules are a bit
different so in our
world maybe energy isn't
a consistent of time and power
maybe it's something else so let's try
and put it in numbers
and actually scientists did this for me
so i didn't do this myself
i'm not that smart as these
portuguese people that actually created
an entire report and research around
energy efficiency and programming
languages
so they checked how energy time and
memory so memories power in this case
related to the consumption of a website
or actually a programming language so it
can also run server side or wherever you
like to run this code
so they took some languages
you can see the list is quite long you
can even see their functional languages
imperative object object-orientated and
scripting languages uh javascript's
actually involved so it's also in object
orientated but also in a scripting
language is someone using javascript for
object orientated stuff
i never tried it or maybe i should the
last time i wrote a class has been long
time ago i mostly the function of
programming
which javascript can do in a way of
course so they took some programming
languages and then they also threw in
some algorithms and it's quite a long
list it actually comes from a computer
language
challenge people try to make challenges
to try to figure out how they can solve
certain algorithms in different
programming languages
and they they took an example binary
trees
probably everyone knows what a binary
tree is because you did them when you
applied for a job right who did a binary
tree when they interviewed somewhere
no one did i think these days most
companies tried to do binary trees
so that's how people probably know them
and they also did something else which
spoke to me even more it's like funko
redux so funko sounds like pancake and
in german and then rudix is something
for react right and it's also an
algorithm and it's quite a fun algorithm
so you would have a set of numbers and
in this set of numbers you would take
the first number and then you should
flip it and reverse the first n number
so if you your first number is a four
you should flip it
you should flip the first four numbers
and you keep doing this until the first
number is one so this is one of the
algorithms they did so does someone try
to dare say how many times they need to
flip it
maybe just shout it or we can try maybe
it's three is it four is it five is it
ten
four
well maybe you're close so it's it's
five times actually so you take the
first number you flip it you reverse it
and you keep doing this so it's five
iterations in total and the final number
should be a one actually pasted is five
over it but if you look at the one with
the four you can probably reverse it in
your head so this was one of the
algorithms they tried and then they
tried it with different set of numbers
of course
so this sounds easy it's a fun redux
algorithm i never heard about it but
it's kind of nice to know
and we did they also
created a table with a total overview of
all this different programming language
so how they would map against
energy consumption the time they took to
solve all these different algorithms and
then also the amount of memory they
allocated
and this is a normalized list so
megabytes is actually memory and you can
see javascript isn't ranking that high
the numbers actually don't say anything
because it's normalized so you don't get
any absolute numbers from here it's also
a different per algorithm but you can
see in general that c is doing very well
pascal is doing very good and i believe
the founder the creator of pascal also
created typescript which somehow is
doing not so well
so you can see except for time
typescript is in the same areas as
javascript
you can probably guess why because you
need to compile it uh to actually run as
javascript so it will take you longer
but you can see javascript is doing
quite bad so luckily php is doing worse
so that's a good thing to see
but something else that compels to me is
rust so a rest is a it's not a new
programming language but it is something
i see more and more javascript
developers get interested in and as you
can see they're doing quite well on this
list so it might be a nice moment to
check it out
so if we go back to our statement the
fast language is often energy efficient
if you look at this list there is no
direct correlation
between time and actual energy it needs
because javascript is taking only
six in a normalized list and then
typescript is taking i don't know let's
say eight times more
but still the energy they consume is
about the same
or not as much difference as within the
time consumption so there is no direct
no direct correlation also if you look
at different numbers so fast languages
often see is often energy efficient is
something that's not directly true
but for a website it's different so if
we get back to the title of this doc how
your bundle size can save the client we
now know javascript might not be the
best language to use but also javascript
has done great things for me and
hopefully for everyone in this audience
so a fast website is often energy
efficient this is something we can
actually test also
and for this we like to look at websites
10 years ago so maybe you remember 10
years ago you opened a website does it
look any different than it does today
i think if you use the wayback machine
from the internet archive you can
actually see it looks quite different
facebook looks old and psy with gangnam
style is somehow popular
so this way back machine actually shows
you websites back in the past i recently
tried this for one of my first websites
actually and it was still there which is
quite cool because i didn't save the
screenshot so if you're here today make
screenshields of all your websites or
use the internet archive wayback machine
but today websites look very different
and much has changed except i found one
website that didn't change in 10 year
so this is hacker news
do you know which one is the older
version is left
or do you think it's right
so people think it's right it's too
small to read properly but it's ten
years different and the website is still
the same so
hacker news probably didn't update their
websites so my statement that websites
look different now is not correctly but
still most websites do look different 10
years later
and nowadays they're also built on
popular javascript frameworks or
libraries
so you have swells of angular hopefully
no longer angularjs your react your few
and also vanilla javascript and probably
there are way more things coming up
and these javascript frameworks they can
be misused quite easily
and if you go back to the top languages
you can see javascript is at the top and
probably most of these people are
building with javascript frameworks or
libraries and maybe not that much people
are building with vanilla javascript
so you can imagine that all these
applications are also consuming lots of
data because as i mentioned except
hacker news all websites now look very
different there's more data involved
there are more images higher quality
videos so websites are consuming more
data and are also bigger than we saw
before
if you look at this one from the
http archive you can actually see the
median size of a website or the median
size of data website consumes is
increasing and it has been increasing a
lot if you go back it's almost a flat
line in the beginning like 10 years ago
and now you can see it's way bigger
people saying their
javascript bundles below 2 megabytes are
probably lying because this is the
average website size
so websites should be optimized for
usage that's something that's really
important to keep in mind so when you're
making your website usable by your users
don't only think about accessibility but
maybe also about the energy efficiency
of your website
because we developers can do that you're
writing the code with your team or by
yourself so you in the end determine
what the product will look like but also
the quality of the go to ship the bundle
size you ship or how accessible your
website is so let's try and put this in
some numbers i actually found a website
that can do this for me you can actually
do it yourself as well just try win some
some loads of performance tests against
your website you will figure it out but
there is a website called website
carbon.com
and it will look at how your website is
impacting the planet on different
statistics on data center data transfers
the energy intensity of your website
also website website traffic which of
course is important because you have a
large bundle size but nobody's looking
at your website maybe remember that side
project
but if the hundred thousands of people
are watching your website every month it
gets more and more important how
efficient this website is so in here you
can actually just paste your own website
and figure out
how good or how bad it is for the planet
and something else they were doing is
quite cool they also look at the energy
source of the data center you can
actually find out there are multiple
websites for this
what your data center is using in terms
of energy so are they using gray energy
or like fossil fuel or are they actually
working with wind and solar energy
so this is public data you can actually
find it online
so let's try it out i took this website
make front front-end again.party
it's built by sarah fieri a great
speaker
and this website is using multiple
javascript frameworks at once so it's
using javascript it's using react it's
also using vue
it uses tons of animated stuff there's
audio on there and
i don't know just try it out it feels
like you're back in the early 2000s or
maybe later and looking at your first
website things are moving all across the
screen
so you can imagine it's a large website
in terms of bundle size there were
little to none optimizations done
you can actually see the bundle size
around 10 megabytes
and something else you know is anyone
using safari as their default browser
except on their mobile phone
some people are it's quite cool if you
go to the developer tab of safari you
can actually figure out how bad or how
good your website is for the environment
you can find the cpu usage of the
website you can also see
it in this list and they actually have
some extensions to look at the carbon
footprint as well
but if we insert this in the website
websitegarmin.com
you can actually see that over one year
with 10k monthly users this website is
using a lot of energy so it's using over
1200 kilowatts of energy which means you
could drive 10 000 kilometers with an
electric vehicle
and also you would need to plant 28
trees in order to
composite the energy this website needs
so this is something you'll see if you
don't do any optimizations and using
multiple javascript frameworks alongside
but maybe even just one on a large
website it is something that can truly
impact the climate
and then we have this motor fm website
which is built with just html so this is
a simple website doing nothing just
playing this data and i tried to to
bleep out all the
all the bad language
uh but you can see it's most it's a
lightweight website it's only 20
kilobytes to load in the browser because
it's just html with text
of course you'll see some javascript
because it needs to render in the
browser
but it is lightweight and you can also
see the cpu usage is bare to minimum i
don't know if you ever look at the cpu
usage of your website i sometimes try to
do it while i'm in
in a video call it's crazy sometimes it
even makes out over 100 but it can also
happen with a website if you have a
large website or bundle that needs
parsing right directory in browser it is
something that can be quite energy
consuming
and this website is actually good for
the climate there isn't much to see so
probably 10k monthly people is like a
stretch
but this website would only need
3 kilowatt hours of energy which isn't
that much it's probably the same as a
light bulb in your house
and you only need to plant one tree to
compensate the energy so even if you
don't have a garden with a balcony you
could maybe plant some small tree or
flower there to actually compensate for
the energy usage of this website
so it's kind of
mind-blowing for me the difference is
huge of course and these are both
well
probably a website you won't build
yourself but it's something to think
about if you have a bundle size that
goes towards a 10 megabyte threshold you
can see the energy impact it has but
only 10k monthly visitors but let's
imagine this is like a large e-commerce
platform or it's maybe a telephone
company that's selling bundles every day
so if you put this alongside you can see
the difference so
to me it really shook my mind if i open
a website i never actually realized that
opening this website will do multiple
things so my computer needs energy to
render this website in my browser which
depending on the bundle size can be
quite a lot and then also the api calls
are actually the data transfers coming
from a data center that is also using
energy to get this data
to the user so there are multiple points
at which you use a lot of energy to show
a website to a user
and
the difference is quite huge
so what can you do to make this better
we already saw javascript might not be
the best language to actually build
to actually build your project in
but then again javascript
runs in the browser and
well other languages don't or at least
most languages don't you always need to
compile them to javascript so recunders
talk to using javascript at least for a
front end for your back end you're
pretty open if you have a server that
can run anything you should be fine
so what can you do there are multiple
things you can do and i'm not a
performance expert
but something you can do is code
splitting of course if you work with
popular javascript frameworks there are
code splitting
code splitting functionalities in there
so you can split your code maybe even a
component level or a page level and this
is something it is quite easy to do and
something that maybe even most front-end
frameworks should do for you so code
splitting is a huge thing actually in
the ecmascript specification you can
find a way to also
do cod splitting by importing
npm libraries
and not importing them every page but
only importing them when you're using
them so these are important things to
think about because maybe whenever
someone is watching the home page of
your website they don't really care what
is behind it on a different different
screen i actually saw products where
people are loading the admin dashboard
whenever you're watching the homepage
well that user might be a regular user
that won't be using your single page
application that runs on the dashboard
so code splitting is a large one
also caching caching is very important
i actually saw websites not using cache
so sometimes the browser helps you
caching which is great you can actually
set the threshold so how long should the
browser cache your website or should
they get your resources these are all
things you can put in the browser you
can actually help the browser with it as
well
compressing is an another important one
if you have a website you can even try
and gzip it and send a gzip to the
browser which will be even faster it
might be using a bit more cpu but really
depending on the use case it can be that
this is actually good for you and then
in gzip there are multiple things or
multiple ways to compress so also have a
look here if your experience you have a
large bundle size a quick and easy fix
is just turn on gzip compression
and then a cdn cdns is something i
really like i always use this example of
a luxury car brand and i won't call the
name because
they they probably don't like it but it
actually started loading a 30 megabyte
video as soon as you open the homepage
and it didn't even autoplay so you open
his website or your mobile phone maybe
you're in a bus or in a tram or on a
train or just sitting here at a
conference and you're trying to buy a
luxury car i hope i could afford it but
still you're getting 40 megabytes of
data in there which is fine if you're in
europe and you have a shared data plan
but let's say you're somewhere else
you're maybe visiting a foreign country
so one of the speakers told me that how
expensive data was in africa if you try
to load this website in africa it's
crazy how much money it will cost you
so cdns are important because they will
help you compress or actually resize the
data that you're loading while also
adding caching
and then static website static website
is a big thing today
maybe people still use the term gemstack
i think most of us have a gemstack
website while the term itself maybe
isn't that alive anymore but static
websites are becoming more important you
already saw it on the example a small
website
take way less data to load and also
because you're not compressing too much
javascript on the browser it's also more
more cheaper for the user actually
loading the website so static websites
are important in most modern javascript
frameworks you even have ways to
incrementally statically build your
website meaning if someone is watching
your homepage and they're hovering over
a product you can actually render
the static website on the server and
then send it to the front end in case
someone actually clicks that button
which of course are also things you
should optimize because you don't want
this running all the time if someone is
just using a screen reader and going to
all the pages but there are multiple
things you can do and as i said i'm not
a
performance expert but these things are
don't have to be complicated if you're
not working at facebook or not working
at amazon it probably doesn't really
matter too much
how you implement these things but how
you
actually start implementing them is the
first step so try and keep these things
in mind whenever building
your website with javascript
and also where your story application
matters i already told you some data
centers are using green energy some
aren't uh probably no one really looked
at where the energy where the data is
stored or and how they store it and if
they're using green energy or gray
energy as sometimes it is called so
green gray energy could be green energy
it could be fossil energy you don't
really know and actually most data
centers operate on gray energy so you
have no idea where the energy is coming
from it might be green it might not be
green it could also be this large is
selling all their green emissions
certificates to someone that is burning
coal to to to render your website so
very story application actually matters
and as i saw before
21 of all the global energy usage is for
the internet so everything we do on a
daily basis is using tons of energy and
it's mostly through data centers so
picking your next
your next data center can also be
important so if you're looking at cloud
providers
google it please and check if they are
using green energy to fuel the data
center
and there's much more data centers can
actually do they can actually reuse the
heat they produce because servers
produce a lot of heat i don't know if
you remember those old desktop computers
they get really warm and noisy and
servers are basically making the same
heat and noise as these desktop
computers
so this extra heat can be used to
actually
heat your home or maybe even a museum or
maybe a school nearby so data centers
can do much more than just producing
energy i come from the netherlands in
the netherlands we have a big problem
with data centers because data centers
are eating away all our green energy
meaning green energy won't go to homes
but it will go to data centers instead
so we need to make sure that these data
centers are actually using the excess
heat they produce to heat those homes in
return so it supported various story
data it's also important how you create
your bundle size
because green energy hopefully is also
becoming the norm maybe at your home if
you have the luxury of being able to
have your own green energy resources
like a solar panel or like a heat pump
but maybe also your energy provider if
you can choose them try and find one
that uses green energy because in the
long run it will help us
and then the final question i guess is
should i stop using javascript so this
is a question people start asking me
i think it's good to be curious and to
experiment with other languages i showed
you which languages are energy efficient
i can also post it on twitter if you
want you can find my handle
on the right button and you can make a
choice maybe you want to learn rust
maybe you want to go back to maybe the
early days if you went to university you
probably learned c or c plus there those
languages are harder to use but they are
more energy efficient so should i stop
using javascript i think you shouldn't i
mean we're with a great group of people
all of in javascript or maybe typescript
and it brought us quite far so you
shouldn't stop using javascript but you
should be aware of how you actually
implement your javascript how you create
your bundle size and where you store
your energy
so with that i'd like to conclude um so
thank you all for listening and if you
have any questions i'll be around for
the rest of the evening so over a beer
or something else to drink i'll be happy
to brainstorm about your ids to make the
world a bit greener thank you